hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com
so for those who are watching this for
the first time let me quickly tell you
what i'm doing here
i used to work as a professional trader
for the past six years in hong kong
and i started to make some youtube
videos because i like to watch
fair fights guys and there is a fight
that has started a war
actually between retail investors and
let's say hedge funds and i'm just here
to make the odds even
so i want to show you everything that i
know that i like to use to set up my
trades
and i want to explain to you guys
everything that i know about financial
markets
and especially about technical analysis
so
today i want to make a huge update guys
on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
so as usual guys i'm gonna start by
reminding you what i
was saying in my last video then i'm
gonna show you the facts that we have
so i'm gonna show you every information
that i'm gonna use i'm gonna explain
how i use it using which method which
indicator
and then i'm gonna show you the
different scenarios and i'm gonna give
you my preferred scenario
with my targets and this is why you guys
are here
i'm gonna give you my targets let me
remind you first the situation
maybe with a little step back so
here basically we're doing this strong
move up
in five ways so we finished the first
wave one
two three four so we are doing here the
fourth wave so i told you basically when
we
were doing the third wave i told you
guys we're going to 35 then correct to
26 then 65
70 and then i told you we're gonna
correct a bit
longer you know because this correction
is a false wave you see
so the force wave should be roughly the
same length in time as the second wave
so
roughly 10 days two weeks and that
when this force wave is gonna be
complete we're gonna do the fifth wave
so this is the reason why i was checking
what kind of corrective pattern we were
having here it was a triangle i showed
you guys this triangle
i told you that the breakout would come
i then told you
that we're gonna correct to 52 guys
which we did
then bounce back and then here
we had this minus six percent that you
know looked a bit
bad but it was just making the
correction lasting a little bit
longer in time but we didn't go deeper
so i told you that we might go as low
as 1.618 uh retracement 11
which was around 48 we didn't even go
there we got we found some support
at the 50 feet retracement area
so 51 yesterday and we strongly bounced
back
so to me the question you guys having is
is this corrective pattern finished
and where is the third wave of the fifth
wave gonna go
and when so i'm gonna try to answer all
these questions
in this video so the first thing i think
that the
corrective pattern which is here the
second wave of this
one two three four five to me is
complete
because you can see that it's already
quite
long i mean you know we often meet
sometime after some deeper correction
like we had in the force wave so it
makes sense for me that we took some
time
but i think that right now it's enough
guys we took enough time
we went deep enough we went twice to the
50 retracement level
and we have a beautiful flat correction
it's actually you know a flat
that you can break down in small abcs
each wave can be broken down in small
abcs like this
okay
and okay so it's actually a combination
of corrective
patterns which is making us
a flat correction right now what you
guys want to see
to be let's say 95 sure that this
correction is complete
we need to break the maximum of wave b
level which is 64 which is the level
where we got
actually rejected guys three days ago i
told you that when we were here i told
you that
this is looking weak to me look at the
macd guys because the magdie was going
lower and we were failing to make a new
high so this was an exaggerated bearish
divergence
so once again the exaggerated
divergences they don't have the same
power
as the regular divergences but here i
think we're going to go back to
64. so this is what i think is going to
happen today
so i'm publishing this video based on
tuesday's close so on wednesday
open i think we're gonna go to revisit
the 64 area
and what is very important guys i don't
want to see here
uh bearish divergence again okay so
imagine we go there but
very like weekly if we go there but with
no power what will happen is that the
macd will stay
actually at low levels and that here we
the macd might be trading only
around zero basically and if this
happens guys this would make
again a bearish divergence i don't want
to see this happen so what i want to see
what is important what you guys want to
see is
some momentum picking up here so we need
to see a maxi breakdown
you can use the breakout method on the
macd as well so the macd
here has a trendline you know we need to
see this kind of
behavior we want to see the macd coming
here very strongly
just before 64. and then when we arrive
at 64 we want to arrive there with
momentum so we're going to break it if
we arrive there
with no more steam no more energy then
the bears might feel good and
increase the short positions if we
arrive there strongly they're going to
be scared like i said already
last time guys they are wounded deeply
wounded and i think that right now is
the time to finish them off
because if we arrive there strongly we
break 64
73 will not hold guys once again the
most recent
the reaction was the better it is so
here
actually my real resistance level
is 64. it's a short-term resistance but
i'm pretty sure that if we break this
one the
kind of bigger one but that happened two
or three weeks ago which is that 73 will
not hold
i don't imagine we break 64 with a maxi
breakdown here
without making a divergence that is
important guys that's what
you need to look at you need to arrive
here with
power and with volumes then it cannot
hold it cannot hold once again the bears
they are already retreating they are
scared
they lost a lot of big battles and they
are here
losing ground and they're gonna just you
know
pull back the orders at safer levels all
right
so i'm gonna talk about this levels we
where they are going to pull back the
orders because of course the war is not
won they're gonna probably put more
short positions for now i think that
here
they're located around the 64 area if we
break this we win this battle they're
not gonna go to the 73 they're gonna be
too scared they're gonna go to the
probably 100 or 135 let me now explain
why we probably gonna go to these levels
what i wanted to show you guys here
once again is very interesting i want to
talk about fibonacci
and elliott wave combined actually so as
usual i go to my bible so this is
the elliott wave book written by frost
and preston you can just find it on
google
ask me i can put the link in the
comments if you want to
and if you go to the page 73
you have actually extremely good
information
very very good information here you have
five different situations and in each
situation elliot
actually gives us some information
between the ratios that you have between
the different waves
so i showed you guys already this one
time i took this example
all right i think it was actually for
amc guys it was to show you that when
this
third wave here is extended wave one is
equal to wave five alright
so today i wanna show you something else
because look what we're having here
look at how big the second wave is
compared to i just want to remind you
guys that we are
discussing about this move all right
you can see and look the second wave of
the fifth wave
is actually bigger than the second wave
itself what does it tell us
what does it tell us guys something very
important here we have a precious
information
we know that the fifth wave if
the fifth phase happens but i think it's
gonna happen and if it happens
it's going to be extended it's going to
be extended so
this gives us actually very good
information here
because you have different situation you
have third wave extension
fifth wave extension first wave
extension and here it's a sum up of this
so in this situation when the fifth wave
is actually extended
you can see that you have this
relationship
so the sum of the first and the third
wave
is equal so the fifth wave is equal to
the sum of it
times 1.618 once again
the golden number so when we apply this
relation
here guys so basically this is what i
already did guys because
i was kind of guessing that the fifth
wave would be extended so this is just
to remind you guys
how i find my levels you measure
the third wave you apply to the bottom
of the force wave
and you take the 1.618 guys so i don't
take
once again these numbers randomly i
don't choose them randomly i take them
from the book
and this book guys is something that i
read it for the first time
i remember like maybe five years ago
i already had a lot of uh techniques
that i was using by myself but when i
read this book and i associated my
techniques with the techniques that i
found
in this book that is like elliott wave
theory combined with fibonacci
i came up with a much more powerful
trading
method and that i'm actually here
showing you guys in my videos that's why
i want to make a full course guys when
i'm gonna explain
everything you know about this method
step by step
i'm gonna basically do some introduction
for beginners
then i'm going to talk about fibonacci
then about the breakouts divergences and
finally about the idiot
waves and from this book for now i just
sum it up
and you can click on the link in the
description of this video and for now
you're just going to receive
introduction to the elliott wave theory
which is already i think very
interesting
but i'm going to do more but for now
what i wanted to show you guys
is that you can use all this information
to actually predict what the market is
going to do
and in this situation it helps us to
find
the targets which is once again here i
get 137
it's an area i guess it's i call it 135
it can be 140 so it's something around
this level and that is given to us by
the fact that the fifth wave is extended
and that we are developing in five waves
and just very quickly guys here i wanted
as well to show you
uh because you might be wondering why is
this fibonacci
golden number used actually by elliot
to find some targets based on the
projection
of the preceding waves that's a good
question and
actually i can show you quickly so what
i'm gonna do so here
is just the introduction of the course i
want to make on fibonacci so you need
first i think to understand what is the
fibonacci sequence all right so
basically
it's this sequence of numbers so
each number is equal to the sum of the
two preceding
ones so here one plus zero equal to one
one plus one
equal to two two plus one equals
three three plus two five five plus
three
eight so on and so forth and this
sequence is something that we can find
in
everything that is growing and you for
example have it in plants
you can also find it for example in
humans in the hand
so for example did you know that the
ratio between
this part of your finger and this part
of your finger is the golden number
and you have the same ratio between b
and c and between a
and b and it also works with the elbow
guys so the ratio between your fist and
your elbow
is actually the golden number it's just
something that i wanted to show you
so you guys you know see things the same
way i actually see them which is that
this golden number
is everywhere in every growing process
and the markets
are just the reflection of the
development of the human economy
so it's a growing process and this is
the reason why elliot
understood that very quickly and he then
decided to apply this ratios
to the waves that he was seeing because
the waves are just for the market
like leaves are for plants or like for
example fingers and hands are for humans
it's just something that is growing and
respecting some
ratios of nature so this is the
information
i wanted to show you guys here so once
again i repeat
what we want to see is we want to get
close to the 64
level with a lot of power so on the
hourly timeframe i want to see this
momentum this magdie
breaking out here and just you know
trade basically higher
here i'm on the macd to trade higher
whenever we approach 64. so we need to
go there
sharply quickly it needs to be a strong
move up if we have this strong move up
and we break 64 then guys we're going
235 in a matter of i think
one or two weeks it should be like this
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys